hey guys we're back i'm talking about
zinc this is part two
if you have not uh seen part one i put a
link down below you can check that out
first
first thing i wanna touch on is uh
depression okay
zinc is a natural antidepressant okay
in patients that have major depressive
disorders they're usually always
deficient in zinc
so if you have depression it's such a
simple remedy
take some zinc it might just help you
but generally if you're deficient in
zinc you get degeneration
of your nerves of your nervous system
now there's a lot of concentration of
zinc in the neurons around the amygdala
and the hippocampus specifically the
dentate
gyrus or gyrus i don't know how to
pronounce him now the amygdala
is this part of the brain that's
involved with stress responses it's kind
of
you can look at it like the adrenal
gland in your brain because it
reacts and adapts to stress the
hippocampus
which they don't know exactly what it
does but it's involved in like a relay
switch
with your memories forming new memories
and spatial memory
like trying to find your way out of some
maze
it's kind of like your gps okay it helps
you locate things
in space now the hippocampus in general
has
a very interesting capacity to
regenerate
and this is why things that are
connected to memory loss
focus concentration can be improved with
intermittent
fasting so well because intermittent
fasting stimulates
the regeneration of this part of the
brain right here
and these structures right here directly
influence
one's mood dopamine for example binds to
zinc so dopamine gives you pleasure
so what's the opposite of pleasure
depression right
also it's involved in like i said before
making
proteins and guess what
neurotransmitters are
they're proteins so if you have any
problem with depression or any type of
mood disorder take zinc it can
potentially help you greatly
all right now let's shift to skin
disorders now you may already know this
but there's so many different skin
creams and
skin healing creams that involve zinc
and if you're zinc deficient you can get
acne eczema
dermatitis many different types of
dermatitis rosacea
a zinc deficiency can dry out the oil in
the skin it's called the sebum
it can lead to ulcers of the skin both
superficially and internally like ulcers
of the stomach or ulcers in the mouth
or even like bed sores one of the
treatments for bed sores is a
zinc cream that you would put on it or
even diaper rash for example irritation
in the skin
you use this zinc so you can look at
zinc as a natural anti-inflammatory
so a zinc deficiency can also lead to
hyperpigmentation on the skin
and alteration in color alopecia
that's where you have hair loss in
different patches this is an autoimmune
condition
cracked skin skin that's fissured
nail changes and skin is the third
most zinc abundant tissue in the entire
body
all right guys stay tuned for part three
when we get into the relationship
between zinc influencing your blood
sugars and insulin
your immune system and the prostate and
testosterone
hey guys real quick i have a new healthy
keto eating plan for you
just go to dr berg.com it's right on the
front page i put a link down below
download it it's free check it out